c'est certainement le seul médecin
escorté par la grc à winnipeg même signé
que deux passages la vie de ce
gynécologue congolais est en danger
partout où il va
en octobre 2013 il échappe à une
tentative d'assassinât devant chez lui à
bukavu dans le sud kivu au congo son
crime
soigner des femmes victimes de viols et
en parler haut et fort à la communauté
internationale la première victime que
j'avais soigner ce n'était pas une femme
qui est venue accoucher
c'est une femme qui était violée à 500 m
de la location de l'hôpital
non seulement il a été violé mais on
avait tiré dans un appareil génital qui
était complètement déchiqueté elle est
arrivée enseignants dans sa vie était en
danger
et voilà une histoire qui va commencer
par un drame
ce n'était pas un fait du hasard c'est
des viols avec tortures
qui sont vraiment bien organisé
méthodique qui se font systématiquement
sur la population les sévices se ferait
en présence des enfants de la famille
pour créer un traumatisme une peur dans
les communautés qui vivent près des
exploitations minières en 16 ans le
docteur denis mukwege et son équipe ont
soigné 54 mille femmes la plupart
victimes des pires violences comme si le
corps de la femme était devenue un
véritable champ de bataille au congo
parce que moi je vois ces femmes à
travers elle je vois ma mère je vois je
vois mes soeurs je vois ma fille je vois
je vois ma femme
aujourd'hui c'est ton vie au congo en
fait c c'est tout simplement une
tragédie une tragédie humaine
quand je vois les enfants qui arrivent à
l'hôpital
l'état des destructions dans lequel ces
enfants s'y trouvent
ce n'est pas d'une guerre tribale ce
n'est pas une guerre nationalistes ce
n'est pas une guerre même des régugiés
fanatiques
c'est tout simplement une guerre pour le
contrôle des richesses du corps et ses
richesses sont contrôlés par en fait
débat les armes et très bien organisée
et qui ont comme fait des connexions
dans les pays voisins et donc les
résultats c'est qui ça fait très très
mal à la population un climat de terreur
instaurée pour permettre le pillage des
ressources minières sans résistance
le viol serait devenue une arme pour
asservir la population pourtant cette
violence a été maintes fois dénoncé par
les nations unies on parle de millions
de morts en 20 ans et sur le terrain peu
de choses changent
le trafic des minerais comme l'or se
fait à ciel ouvert c'est un marché qui
rapporte une des matières convoité le
coltan sarah produire le tantale à métal
précieux pour la fabrication des puces
de téléphones cellulaires
son prix auraient augmenté de 2000 % en
50 ans 70% du coltan la cassitérite qui
intervient dans nos téléphones mobiles
d'un laptop provient de cette région et
séminaires et il ya la possibilité de
les avoir de façon propre on peut les
avoir sans sacrifier les femmes on peut
les avoir 100 mutiler les femmes on peut
avoir ces mines erré en fait où la
population locale peut gagner et les les
multinationales qui qui les exploitent
peuvent également gagner
la torture est pas des objets aussi bien
compte en banque et tranchant dans le
docteur mukwege et parcourt le monde
avec le même message il est ici à
winnipeg lors d'une levée de fonds pour
son hôpital
parmi les gens qui le soutiennent le
sénateur roméo dallaire qui a été témoin
du génocide au rwanda il ya 20 ans
l'histoire se répète
je pense que je pense que c'est encore
pire avec toute notre apprentissage
depuis les derniers 20 ans et tout les
outils qu'on accueille les politiciens
sont tout aussi les dix ans et non plus
à intervenir
à moins que c'est dans leur intérêt donc
je les trouve à quoi plus coupable
[Musique]
mais il ya des signes d'espoir le groupe
armé n 23 accusés de violences a été
dissous un des chefs de guerre est
actuellement devant le tribunal de la
haye il y a un an les onze pays de la
région des grands lacs ont signé un
accord de paix on mettre un terme au
conflit sanglant du congo mais sur le
terrain les femmes continuent d'affluer
à l'hôpital panzi à bukavu avec la même
sordide histoire même en quittant
l'hôpital
j'avais enregistré des cas qui venait
d'être violée en moins de 112 heures
donc ça continue les bandes armées sont
encore là et je crois qu'il faut une
détermination il faut une volonté
politique pour que ce groupe armé on
puisse le mettre hors d'état de nuire ni
docteur vous pouvez gay s'était réfugié
en suède en 2013 après l'attentât contre
sa personne et ce sont les congolaises
et femmes du kivu qui l'ont fait revenir
en se cotisant ont payé son billet
d'avion de retour il est accueilli en
héros
il vit désormais dans l'enceinte de
l'hôpital pour des questions de sécurité
il continue d'opérer en se posant la
même question depuis 16 ans quand est ce
que la communauté internationale va se
réveiller
mapei nord